[音楽]
えこんにちははみ社長ですえ皆様2024
年あけましておめでとうござい
ます
そしてHIKAKIN
さんご婚おめでとうござい
ます置いてかれた
キさん結構おめでとうございますはい明け
ましておめでとうございます動画なんです
けどももうそれどころじゃないなんとあの
YouTubeの王HIKAKINさんが
ご結婚されまし
[音楽]
た
えっとあのすいませんね毎回このなんか
YouTuber中のいい
YouTuber結婚すると動画を撮っ
てるんですけども今回はちょっとあの次元
が違う2024年1月の1日課金さんがご
結婚されました女性一般女性の方と結婚さ
れたみたいでもう大衝撃と言いたいところ
なんですけどもちょっとだけ知ってました
でそんな詳しい話はしてないんですけども
うっすら話はちょっと親分本人からお聞き
しててあのあの200023年ぐらいかな
なんかひょっとしたら年代に結婚するか
もってこと聞いてたんですよいいでしょう
ちなみにあのこの発表が出るまで誰にも
言ってません親分誰にも言ってませんよ
安心してくださいあの僕の周りの人とか誰
にもそういう話はせずに僕はこの日を待っ
ておりました待ってたんですけどなんか
年代に結婚するって聞いてたから2023
年中に結婚されなかったからあれ亡くなっ
たのかと思ったらまさかの2024年1月
1日にご結婚されるということでびっくり
しました本当に
いや本当に心からおめでとうございますっ
ていう天使のはじめ社長親分の幸せを願う
天使のはじめしちとあれあれあれ親分僕は
今まであのいろんなYouTuber結婚
してきたのにHIKAKINさん結婚され
てなかったから大丈夫かなと思っていたの
に結婚したからなんかやばいとすげえ動揺
してる悪魔のはめ社長が今本当に入り乱れ
てるんですけどどっちかというと天使勝っ
てますさすがにめでたい本当におめでたい
ですかさん本当におめでとうございます
どうしようえ俺どうしよう本当
にまあでもいっかもう逆にここまで来ると
開き直っ
ていやわかんない
な結婚したいのかな俺なんか最近したいの
かしたくないのかもよくわかんなくなって
きました幸せな一面もあるけどもちろん
家庭を持つということは幸せな分大変な
こともきっとあると思いますそれを
乗り越えられるだけのえ信頼できる女性に
会うまでは僕はもう結婚はしません
そもそもいるかも分かりません今のところ
はいませ
んなんでそういうちょっとプライベートな
2024年のプライベートな目標としては
もうあのHIKAKINさん結婚しまった
のかやばい引きずってんなおいおやぶ置い
てかないってま2024年の目標は自分
らしくにしますはいもう周りが結婚したり
周りは人は人の幸せがあるん
です果たしてそうなのでしょうか結婚家庭
生涯を共にする人と一緒になるこれ以上の
幸せは本当はあるのだろうかとも思います
がそれは人それぞれなんか俺悟りの境地に
言ってますねなんで本当に皆さん驚かれた
と思いますけどもHIKAKINさんと
結婚された女性か俺は会ったことないん
ですけどあの神と言れるHIKAKIN
さんとご結婚される方なので多分
すごい人なんだと思いますめちゃくちゃ
素敵な方ときっとご結婚されたと思うので
私初め社長はえ心からお祈りん本当に素敵
な方とご結婚されたことは間違いないので
心から親分そしてえ嫁さんの幸せを祈って
おりますでこんなカメラに言っててもあれ
なのでちょっと本人呼んでみましょう
ヒカキン
さんHIKAKINさん
ご
結婚おめでとうございますありがとう
ござい
ましおご
ますいや
ハローYouTubeどうも2024年1
月1日に結婚したヒカキですおめでとう
ございますお結婚ですありござちょっとね
結婚しましたって叫びすぎてちょっと声
枯れてるんですけどすあそっかそうそう
そうそう
先見まくってるんですね世界一ギネス登録
されるぐらい行ってるからすごいかもう
びっくりしました本当にあ良かっ
たでもそうそう俺もなんだろうな動画を
あげてみてどういう反応かこのこの動画今
撮ってる時点でも全然わかんないからいや
本当にそうですよねあのどうなってるか
なっていういやでも親くが今
34で今年年明けて5になる年35の年
なるほどです
ねこう
え追いたが
ない若いから始めいやいやいやだってだっ
てだってもう30ですから30ですけど見
てください周りシルが結婚したりとかそう
ね徹夜結婚とかはいはいもうなんかね去年
とかラッシュなよね本当にそうですでこう
タンタンタンてきてああもうなんかみんな
YouTuber結婚してるなと思って
けど親まだは結婚してねから大丈夫かと
思ったら結婚してるじゃないですかそうな
んですよはいありがとうございますお
めでとうございますありがとうございます
までもねあの普通だと思うんでね結構
なんて言うんですか都市的にはそうですね
はいはいはい
ええいやそうねタイミングもちょっとね
そのほらなんかこうまどこでもいいのかも
しれないけど寒くなってきた頃にあ演技の
いい日の方がいいかなとか言って検索し
たらなんか12月31日と1月って出てき
てすごいまさに年末年始ですねそうでも
なんかこう覚えやすいのとうんうんうん
なんか特にま元日うんだとなんか日の出感
あるじゃんはいはいはい確かにから
スタートというかねうんなんか去年のこ
ってよりかは今年のことってしたいから1
月1日かいやあ素敵すぎる本当におう
ございいありがとうござい
ます
おまだってねほら彼女いるもんねおねあの
いませんオマイガいませんオーマイガ
ちょっとこれはもう本当に僕の中の衝撃
ですよそうだよねでかいすHIKAKIN
さん結婚があの本当にでかいなんか親分で
も分かるんですよ絶対素敵な夫になる
イメージができてるやハードル上がるなま
でもねあのただYouTubeは変わらず
やりたいうんと思ってるのでそれを妻も
理解してくれてはいるのであのできるだけ
変わらずいや
もうこれからもぜ結婚生活も含め親の幸せ
な人生を祈っております本当におめでとう
ございますありがとう
ござい
[拍手]
[音楽]
おい
これ絶対サムネタイトル置いてきないで
ください